[Music]
Michelle is here because Selena's best
friend Taylor Swift just released her
new music video here's the question
could it be about her new man Joe Alex
well that's what the Swifties are saying
Kevin they are loving this and the song
is called
ready for it the answer is yes Taylor we
are
are you ready for ready to take on
herself in the most epic of ways
[Music]
Swifties can't stop talking about that
skin-tight cyborg silhouette
it's an electrifying look which seems to
be inspired by Scarlett Johansson's
character in the sci-fi thriller ghost
in the shell'
[Music]
on Instagram Taylor posted some
behind-the-scenes photos of what is
actually a fully covered latex bodysuit
then there's the slew of symbolic
statement starting with her boyfriend of
eight months Joe Allen
[Music]
in the first scene check out that
graffiti in the back 89 is a nod to the
year she was born and the 91 in yellow
could be a reference to chose birth year
1991 then there's her ex Calvin Harris
it's speculated the visuals of these
lightning bolts are a literal
interpretation of the lyrics she
secretly co-wrote on his song this is
what you came for
[Music]
the overall message taylor is breaking
free from haters but unlike bad blood
when she was armed with her squad this
time taylor's at it alone defeating her
toughest enemy yet herself are you ready
fire oh and taylor just a little
appreciation from one woman to another
you are given body in that bodysuit her
new album reputation comes out on
November 10th and gets it she gave her
fans a little sneak peek she held a
secret listening session at her
Nashville home and the fans either left
with a little parting gift that's really
really cool huh
[Music]